تركيز قوات الاحتلال على المناطق الجنوبيه
كيف تقرا الاشتباكات واطلاق الصواريخ
المستمر من شمال القطاع باتجاه مناطق غلاف
غزه جلال هذا الامر هو الهاجس في المرحله
الرابعه التي يعد لها جيش الاحتلال يعني
هو ينتقل بى المرحله الثالثه في الشمال
ويحاول فرض المرحله الثالثه على الوسط
ولكن تبدو المرحله الاولى والثانيه هي في
جنوب غزه حيث الحده الاشتباكات هي مرتفعه
جدا يبقى هاجس الانفاق وهذا ما يتحدث عنه
كل المسؤولين العسكريين ويبقى هاجس اطلاق
الصواريخ حتى ولو قلت عدد اطلاق الصواريخ
كما يدعي جيش الاحتلال ولكن تبقى القدره
على الحركيه على تامين اللوجستيه على
القصف وهذا الامر
سيضع عقبات كثيره جدا للمرحله الرابعه
التي يعد لها جيش الاحتلال حتى الوصول الى
ما تسميها المرحله الرابعه تركيز القتال
بهذا الشكل المكثف والضاري على منطقه
خانيونس وعلى الجنوب بشكل عام الى ماذا
يؤشر بالساعات والمرحله
المقبله اهم المعارك جلال هي تدور في غرب
خان يونس لانه اذا نظرنا الى التوزيع
السكاني والابنيه دائما خان يونس بمساحه
54 م ككل دائما الكثافه السكانيه هي في في
شرق خان يونس من هنا يعتمد جيش الاحتلال
طريقه التثبيت والتهديم على حدود غزه على
الحدود مع الكيان الاسرائيلي بسبب انشاء
المنطقه العازله كما يدعي وبالتالي اللعبه
الاساسيه والمرحله المعركه الفاصله هي
ستكون في اي غرب خان يونس لانه تعتبر خان
يونس هي مركز الثقل للمقاومه ومركز الثقل
ل جيش الاحتلال من هنا هو يسرع هذه
العمليه وبالتالي حتى يسقط من الجو
اللوجستيه ويسقط من الجو كل شيء يتعلق
بالقتال لانه طرق المواصلات واللوجستيه
ليست مؤمنه حتى ولو كانت
المسافات قليله وقصيره ذكرت العميد الياس
ما يسميها الاحت خلال المنطقه العازله وهو
الذي يسعى اليها من خلال التدمير الكلي
للمباني المتواجده هناك كيف تقرا هذا
السجال العسكري السياسي بين حكومه بنم
نتنياهو والاداره الامريكيه الرافضه لاي
بقاء طويل القوات الاسرائيليه داخل قطاع
غزه جلال هناك توزيع للادوار على المستوى
الجيوسياسي والاستراتيجي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هي تعتبر حامي لهذه العمليه في
الداخل غزه هي تردع الجبهات المختلفه
وبالتالي هي تؤمن الغطاء السياسي ان كان
في مجلس الامن او الجمعيه العموميه
وبالتالي هي تؤمن الذخائر يعني فلنتذكر ان
هناك اكثر من 250 شحنه كارجو اتت الى
اسرائيل عدا 20 سفينه وبالتالي ذخيره
القبه الحديديه الميركافا وحتى حتى
المدفعيه ال 155 وهي اصبحت عمله نادره
ولكن هناك الاداره الجيوسياسيه ولكن
الحريه التكتيكيه على الصعيد الداخل في
غزه اسرائيل قادره على فرض امر واقع ومن
هنا عمليه التدمير الممنهجه حيث قتل ما
يقارب ال 20 21 جندي في تفجير المنزل هذا
من ضمن هذه العمليه لانه الصوره
المستقبليه التي تريدها اسرائيل في غزه هي
على الشكل التالي مرحله ثالثه في الوسط في
الشمال وفي الجنوب وبالتالي المنطقه
العازله والانتقال الى ما يسمى بعمليه
الروتين او الروت عمليات بسيطه جمع
المعلومات استخبارات وبالتالي القيام
بعمليات محدده ومكثفه في مكان ما ولكن
يبقى كما اتى في في التقرير خطر الصواريخ
يعني ماذا تنفع المنطقه الامنه بكيل متر
عمق من لحمايه للحمايه ضد الصواريخ تبقى
المشكله الكبرى الصواريخ والان طيب انت
ذكرت ايضا التدمير الممنهج وهو بدا من
الشمال مرورا بالوسط وصولا الى الجنوب هذا
الزخم الكبير للعمليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في الجنوب في في خان في
خانيونس الى ماذا تسعى القوات الاسرائيليه
وما مصير ما بعد خانيونس على سبيل المثال
رفح منطقه حساسه بالنسبه ل لمصر وما يعرف
ايضا بمحور فيلاديلفيا هل تضغط اسرائيل
نحو مواجهه مرتقبه في في في هذه المناطق
لاحقا يقال وحسب المعلومات انه لاستكمال
العمليه العسكريه في غزه يجب الانتقال من
خان يونس هذا اذا استطاعت الانتقال من خان
يونس جلال خان يونس ستكون المعركه الفاصله
وبالتالي الانتقال الى م الى رفح موضوع
اخر يتطلب جهد اساسي والحروب عاده فيها
عمليات توقف الحروب ليست مستمره عند كل
مرحله من الحروب يجب التوقف لقياس تقيييم
الواقع العسكري مقارنه مع الواقع السياسي
اما محور فيلادلفيا او كوريدور فيلادلفيا
فهو امر مختلف تماما تماما يتطلب اتفاقيات
وموافقه من الحكومه المصريه لانه بالعام
2005 عد لملحق الامني لاتفاقيه كم ديفيد
والمتعلق بالامن في صحراء سيناء كي بعد
الخروج الاسرائيلي المستوطنات يعني من
داخل غزه هذا الامر يتطلب الموافقه من مصر
واعلن الرئيس السيسي البارحه قبل البارحه
انه يعني لن يقبل بهذا الامر